thank you
um
okay good morning everybody
um
[Music]
products
I'll go through the pages page three
four
page six two
yes regarding the census we've got me
more later information
in the mind
regarding the sentences
which would you like to come in with
that magic instead of waiting
yes Jack thank you um I was going to
raise it and uh yeah and the forward
plan or the census information we've
been told is coming out today so I'm
hoping that we'll be able to get some
reports and everything ready for your
next meeting if that's all it can make
you great so when we come to that if you
want to add that in gender well I just
check we haven't had the email yet so
it's not done as well yet but it's
supposed to be out today
all right
thank you very much yeah okay page seven
I think
if anyone can confirm that
I'm not aware of any formal review
taking place
um I know the the LJ and Other Bar Needs
have been lobbying government uh
interested in a review should take place
and it should be up with it but I don't
think that's been agreed by government
but yeah so there's no information to
say that it is
[Music]
the housing department
[Music]
[Music]
on this
situation
and I think it's well recognized there's
property values and it comes to kind of
way to go to the bank name uh prices and
again an interesting degree and they've
been
um
many years prior to handle I think
um
right
thank you
um
[Music]
extensions okay
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
contributions
[Music]
decorated an interesting role understand
about the decorations
[Music]
agreement between agenda part one and
two we have another part two
so we'll get into item number eight
which is Grant maintenance
well thank you for inviting
um
in April
um it's been an interesting time
um it's been a well actually accepted
for the first six months in degree
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and without to be fair at the South
we're very pleased about well I said
that is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
um
because we moved into the requirements
we need a draft even though their
salutations throughout the
um
[Music]
and the teams were lifted no matter
stuff that we had uh that was found and
the things about things
foreign
[Music]
um and credits of interesting benefits
members that I know that there were
significant number of Defense previously
like I said they have reduced that said
uh we used to build a complaint when it
comes in that we're aware of is
the service um
[Music]
improve that for everybody
to have more security emotional but
they're having an efficient way of doing
that
um
they also bringing into operations are
um
where we've got our asset where our land
it works all intensity but then
throughout Capital will go in
with
[Music]
[Music]
um
I obviously he's recorded so apparently
did not breaking for the buildings
um
[Music]
so that that's sorted an error there
were places
[Music]
product
contract
[Music]
with the decisions of food and so
that did gives us a significant amount
to get ahead and to get back to it I
know what I call yeah
is if nothing's been done for two years
it's going to take twice as well
um and we've had a lot of comments about
the sugar work around the district
um
about the secretary a number of the
other side
so yeah I'm sad um
District
[Music]
the key thing about the classes before
yeah
um okay
[Music]
um so going forward
as in any contract when you cut when you
do certain things
we know how the flexibility to students
to be members requirements
who uses areas
[Music]
[Music]
as well
that their daughter made are they said
that you you didn't agreement want them
to be areas where they took out which
couldn't remainder couldn't enormous
many times because that's their
breakdown and that's what brings there
uh
the latest approaches we've done and all
these things have been a higher I think
it's beneficial events
um we produce
okay
and then
um
in no time at all but also what it
enables us to do is enchantment objects
because we're doing more with our
understanding
we're creating more organic matter we're
creating more weight
to take away the subject
Rochester but we've all been shredding
amongst the material to make a compost
like material that we don't actually
understanding we were a lot more the the
branches
[Music]
really
um I'll just take any questions
[Music]
um
thank you chair yes uh well with my um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anybody else a question Peter
yeah congratulations to Richard for a
sort of smooth transition to work your
thing and obviously welcome
um that's you're going to consider the
biodiversity situation
when you settle in I think maybe in the
spring we talked about
um
it's I take on board your points about
neatness and public wanting things to
look nice there is you know it's just
possible to have biodiversity and to
satisfy the Aesthetics of the public
seem to want and this has been applied
in most of other areas for other local
authorities so I look forward to
discussing that with you just to read
things you talked about the streamers
being knit from the storage
um did you replace any with cordless
ones no
uh not colder as well
yeah
instead of the paperwork
um we have the irony is they took a
pattern once
and all of the battery was
actually together
in charge so it was like the right so I
didn't replace any
batteries with petrol it was like the
right before what we had okay
um
[Music]
leaves and grass cuttings do you compost
those
so the intention is is that it's like
everything you just have to ask about
things
I'm going to keep 10 minutes and then
we're doing the same compost we can
shred the branches into the final
branches in with the grass patterns
together
so that is what will be
um the majority of Our Lives that will
be used you know we don't collapse on
all of the land that we have and that's
the big issue that we've had we've
looked at regular time this is a bit of
using the contract there so the fact
that Senator Tyler
[Music]
sit down without getting heavy so with
the shortage of it will be happening we
only come in a number of likes of the
fourth Mission reply
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
same to that or used by Tiffany
[Music]
try that
but they will try better not just sound
but the guys you know the Escape will
learn more uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
sure
yeah
[Music]
um
[Music]
some Indian people from London they are
also celebrating it in India
[Music]
um
but I know there's some issues with so
where you've made those intimidated
[Music]
um
about
[Music]
[Music]
the services they've been taken now
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um if you have a dedicated tool in one
area
that wasn't the case
down
um okay
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is the times are known as I do I have
one complaint at the time of the body
that has no pain and I will tell you my
emails are there is
[Music]
huge I'm talking about culture with us
at the other marriages
um
[Music]
anything
[Music]
um the requests come through for funding
of um transport
um
is that the volunteers
applied to the local commissioner
and see if they can be funded because it
will be
[Music]
very important
the the transfer during the times I mean
just one path
and that's the problem
but that's what
thank you
across the district
um
which
[Music]
thank you
okay and yes I'd just like to speak on a
problem investment
a problem
not in your making
um the we have volunteered on the
receiver on the green uh and they kept
it well in order but unfortunately one
of the neighbors stopped at letting them
use
[Music]
and the database okay that they have the
volunteers have finished
um I'm delighted to hear just recently
that works in a take place former
um
and
I'm just concerned don't have rewarded
the blind post at hand if you could just
have an outside tap on getting the
recordings I think it is practicing
volunteers coming back but I would also
like to say that all your stars are
exceedingly polite I do receive comments
from the general public they are in a
professionally new ground Bank
thank you
anybody else to Richard
no
thank you for that thank you
we've got interested you're doing a
moment but you always do
all right
yes
come on finally I'm going to imagine
yeah all right okay
[Music]
okay we'll move on to item nine now
which is India and David is going to
give us a little bit of a lecture I
think
obviously just passing on information
um I'll just quickly go through the
financial aspects of the EQ guide I mean
you've all been naming to ask questions
in advance of the meeting
have you just go to page 13 of your
thoughts but I think page 13. it just
showed highlights on income on the first
page so it'll start many examples so you
can't marketing and going down some line
charges
um I'm not going to go through line by
line and replace yourself what I really
want to say is Anchor is either of both
has everybody got page
13.99
is going downwards
[Music]
right yeah
Target
so actually there's been convention to
councilors before the financial pressure
is based in the council are expenditures
are there not implementation which is
our problem is our expenditure which is
our issue
um just at the bottom uh you've got uh
talking about the salary monitoring and
to a Broadcasting
understands against
budget in terms of vacancies but we've
got an expenditure tracker so have you
just moved on to the next page this is
one of the more important page
so you've got three boxes
the top box which said pretty monitoring
revenue and you go over to where it says
net variance and then if members can see
that I think about 658 673 have anybody
see that bigger yeah
so that is a headline figure for the
forecast overspend for The Current
financial year however there's a very
very big copy element to that thing
if you go to the right hand box and I'm
going to say green
and he sees I forget it says release
money has been reserved 552 000 and it's
in random in Brackets
the headline figures that are often 659
000 is after called refurbishing result
essentially with looking at Reserve that
we can let go the very amount of
purposes about we're not going to
proceed I would often more proceed in
any meaningful timetable so in reality
we've dipped into the family silver to
reduce the oldest man so if you compare
if you just you hadn't done that
so about 552 000 hadn't released from
reserves would be our normal spend 1.2
million which compared to an overspend
last quarter of 1.1 million so
essentially we're still in the same
place
okay so maybe so we've just gone the
left hand side of the box I think that's
an apologize yeah
um headline figure who's headline figure
last and all uh last quarter Etc again
we forecasted over spend 1.867
000 are both being related to
homelessness the action device
and this is the old Spanish budget
right clearly that's the biggest
advantage of pressure at the council
faces
and we still haven't got a solution
Council
um
the next variance below star costs
um two big things here really one is the
payroll the payroll has been accepted
and the payroll was a flat rate of
1925 pounds per
um salary height
so everybody got the same increase
obviously programs have a part-time
employees so I get the same and pay
award as my staff
[Music]
range
but that was far in excess of the budget
that we set aside which was two percent
and that obviously less than the pay
award reflects inflation and it also
requires a public building learning have
indicated have now and done an increase
in minimum wage and we haven't been
doing anything a local Authority sector
without scale finds out a lot of the
minimum wage which is very unacceptable
if you have a big pressure on Staffing
costs is the cost of agency
so that could be agency Richards area in
the operating with drivers
but also increasing because of the
recruitment difficulties but we're using
agency stuff and I thinking areas were
traditionally not used which is health
and benefits and council tax completely
non-use
um
going down there's no one not much
massively different transport utilities
that's pretty much a standard latinum
but you know just to give an example of
something well-known
um there is an insurance
um I think a lot of people went around
the percentage of the budget of
um 56 000 related to isn't one percent
it's 25 we don't spend that much energy
but our insurance contracted linked to
inflation so it's linked to whatever RPI
was in September so obviously
increase but also with insurance it's
linked to the rebuild cost of the
council's premises so we have to give
them they revalue our assets of this
film in Rivers Bank West Club Etc passed
down and because it costs them all to
really build those premises to the
Consulting classification the insurance
premium has gone on
so you want to try my exercise
we are are all in Spanish at the
previous page was all right
on target we will Target it's all about
potentially if we just move up available
treasury deposits
412 000 if you look at that percentage
of budget quite clearly I didn't get the
budget right on that one burned in our
state of interest rate we're going to go
up to now in the shots
good news
when we pop that out we'll get great
rates of return I wonder that reflect
well I'm going to go before and other
things like the environment Center where
we put it into borrow on it that's an
expanded trip tracker we're talking
about
um
active in the next under spend I've said
it before it's actually more about what
do you development
[Music]
um we continue to get some bits of Grant
income but all the various government
mandates for it uh not what it was in
the rights of the covert
um years but you know on the energy
rebate which is where everybody is
paying accounts I've got 150 pounds
while they have energy bill we're
currently administering the third trance
of household of the book of heart attack
before payments and we get some funding
for government administrators
um
so the headline is the real old
respective is near 1.2 million there
what will reform is 659 000 but that's
because we get into Reserve to do so
okay so
um
skip the next page that's basically what
I'm just articulate into
page six you know at least in the
short-term treasury products
[Music]
and if you
look just to see how volatile the market
is at the moment if you go to the top
one which says the Archer Building
Society you can really see that but I
don't know about it yeah we place um 5th
of July
and we've gone to 2.46
we go down to the bottom one said
Goldman Saturn which will be placed in
September
1971 so that's more than doubled
then and amongst his on July
so there's correctly a little volatility
in the market
um have you noticed about the hash when
I replaced 20 million pounds uh deposit
about three million they're about to get
the interesting
and we sat on that amount of money for a
couple of reasons we've still got a
little bit of government grants
[Music]
[Music]
um
unfortunately
we did have some ethical Investments
um we can't get any ethical Investments
at the moment because nobody's offering
any electrical Investments over children
0.2 percent of the best we can achieve
and there's one on our list that we
could do Goldman Circle unfortunately
their minimum investment is 25 million
we don't have 105 million and also it
reaches down to a United policy anyway
so that's a normal starter
uh we just moved to page 17.
on the capital
I mean landing on this one is we haven't
really progressed too much because some
of the big headline projects haven't
started about the environment Center I
would hope to please come pick up in the
capital program cheaply and we can start
delivering some Hospital accommodation
which are one of the benefit of reduced
in our expenditure on temporary
accommodation
um it wasn't for 10 and 10 minutes to
going into Purpose with finances unless
anybody questions
any question
[Music]
um
[Music]
which is important
yes
sorry you want pizza
are we um yeah we're getting we're
discussing a response there's a lot of
real questions of this we will end up
watches
don't finish this bit then we'll go on
to the questions with the aurelian
waiting for him
anybody else oh Steve you want to do
yeah just you know obviously the biggest
especially results
I've been gone
um
[Music]
[Music]
that's our biggest problem in all
options in terms of peculine additional
accommodation Hospital accommodation
that is I mean basically every week at
smt is on the agenda yeah but it is I
can't exercise
in the council
we have spent more in the first place
than any of the University that are
negatively ensures for spending the
protected by Republic at all times
as much so we're moving as quickly as a
couple of minutes it just became secure
parts of accommodation overnight but
it's almost like you know one of the
very main photos I've watched them to
continue to tend to do so
I'm interested
foreign
[Music]
Revenue
[Music]
it's only three thousand pounds cover a
variety of Services
HR I'd say
um
[Music]
thank you homelessness
[Music]
[Music]
right
anybody else you didn't ask why the
finance managers
right okay
on the um 7
[Music]
000 846 it seems you could spend
that is fair laws
what happens
what seems to be this sort of indicates
and so it forces us to uh approve
planning applications and since it's all
constrained earlier but I mean do we
have another magic drawer no
but In fairness that hasn't actually
particularly gone down if you went about
six years probably accumulated that
appeals reserved actually gone up in
value rather than gone down everybody in
prison place
the truth about it there's a big appeal
that we lost him we could have a case
not very species that we discussed in
our source response to indeed it would
increase the old depend on the council
all right
sure yes
that hasn't been undertaken that's
something that's quite a plan
how many uh
um
it was more to create a family and more
suitable accommodation but of course
while we've got all our hospitals going
full there's no conducted to to read
houses So the plan would be as we secure
new parts of accommodation people will
be rebound into a better life
to be remodeled or until you've got
super open accommodation to put people
too that's not viable
very well
anymore any more questions
no
yeah
there's no more questions for that so
let me just asking questions on the
budget the cycle of Aquarius on the
other QPR so we're going to change
we're just asking yeah
okay okay
um
I was also I got a planning question
here I've been asked by councilor to
help would ask to ask for help
developing a support on how they fit
into the body and planning housing
allocation at Broadband but it seems to
know what we're going to the allocation
has reached towards what's being
developed or given a permission to pause
it's near to what the allocation is for
Northern Area and if so are we going to
stop to any of the further development I
think that's council with myself
it's under planning I'm talking about
and I think there's a planning thing
about slow how much we've developed how
many applications have been what they
doing
I've got a page 27 I think
uh house or 27 pounds
um
[Music]
in reversal there's a section of where
provided
[Music]
well that's hopeless again
net additional earned provider is that
what you're looking at yeah I mean that
has relevance and also the degree assist
you up here it's
um I think it's probably best of our
second please you know sort of planning
department yeah
God save Helen yeah
verse there's a concern about
yeah I had one here
um about a waste management Richard and
Richard's
um I'll ask him safely about that it's
about the websites and how we go to the
black opportunity to go with it
underways management yeah yeah as well
it's our best
um I also had something here about
[Music]
um
yeah we've gotten there yeah
who transferred that which we've been
asking for
this is nothing to do with the QPR when
you're asking
um yeah I did Source do we not have a
section on how the legal department is
performing on the
[Music]
qbridized chairs it's just a big
performance in the leaders that step
with a handful and an attack during that
business and strategic plan so anything
easy
in terms of details or transfer is like
a bit like that exactly any questions
[Music]
[Music]
so it's not relevant that we should
assess the performance
performance
[Music]
Sports okay I don't have many uh foreign
[Music]
but if you're suggesting that then
things we hadn't noticed version over
and then I I would object to that but
it's going away
but I've been told I'm not supposed to
raise it but I mean that is
[Music]
legal department
I'm sorry okay you know I'm entitled to
raise things
we're
the questions and answers yeah oh sorry
um
no idea I mean that's probably why
fairness canceled I think that's why we
have the questions
in advance because
when this was brought in we'd have too
many times people that's the opposite of
the question and you're not mastered
with everything so we'd have to go I
don't have to go back to you so having
the questions in advance it allows us
time to formulate better
I'm trying to think of the answer what I
was saying I mean I don't know where
that is
and
right we're going to go on questions and
answers
[Music]
um
Christopher will give you an answer
there yeah are you happy no that's fine
and there's been some press coverage as
well yeah um the main concern is
but you're happy with that answer
move on to the next question then that's
the problems
for that question and um
are you happy
yes
yes I would think so yeah yeah so that
maybe go by the way down
right and if that's the case that we
actually have done the ways to actually
developing masks
um
[Music]
[Music]
okay we'll look at um
that question
David ages
[Music]
um
yes I just wonderful are we looking at
everything as a class Center in other
words the car parts
um
no there's not that direction I could
actually do that as a setback because I
thought we had a capital budget we've
got about 180 000 pounds every year into
the capital some of that is about a
research center but some man has been
reserved it for fives actually that we
don't there uh
in capital yeah so um cash turned the
car park generation
in terms of you were a public business
but you could touch or chapter spend you
know so it's hot
at my salary of course which state
salary the I.T
we don't do that exercise
okay
[Music]
this question
no problem
um oh your question
um
[Music]
this kind of sort of expressed his
concern about sort of the Investments
we've got and the fossil fuels
particularly and you've got a swirly
um agreed that we should put centers in
ethical
um
David talks about 0.6 and I'll get a
raise so I mean what implications does
that have for the income only two plus
it's basically
but basically we said when we said don't
be management policy to allow us to do
that become a green investment yeah so
we were prepared to do it if the cost of
the council's margin I think it was 2
000 pounds per million pound investment
yeah so that's why I can't go against
the policy that was approved by Paul
Council constrain what we can do in
terms of management so Peter who's the
deputy section it's our first emergency
person
essentially
really close to the best you can get
he'll go with the green the Market's
changed almost recently digital address
they're just not there because uh you
know it's the council list
to take a bigger loss of income to do
agreement but yeah at this moment in
time David we can't take nobody
[Music]
they're the only ones offering at this
time yeah I think within the fixed one
UK UK based financial institution we're
fixed at 180. that we've locked up here
they're the only ones we had I think we
had one with blind before we were
constrained about uh
yeah that's our policy the policy of the
fixed F1 rating is you know to financial
institutions with financial institutions
with a good rating yeah
thank you
yes
thank you very much uh it's not a
question is to support uh
conversation and their response and uh
on section one by one officer is
delivered a pitch on ratings are there
to protect us all exactly uh we do not
want to revisit the Icelandic scandals
where councils lost all sorts of money
by trying to
um
yeah getting high interest rates yeah
and at the moment we have got to be
incredibly prudent with what we are
doing so we don't open up any further
deficits in our accounts yeah so uh I
commend this response that we've been
given today the time is not now
I don't disagree with what you're saying
uh Council Hayes we yes we've been
declare the climate emergency and one of
the issues was that we would look at
ethical Investments but perhaps in the
coming months this is not the time to be
taking a reduced amount to make a a
return on our investment right thank you
yeah
okay uh
um yeah
yeah emergency
right
[Music]
um
I think it's um Ian as well
something similar
um yeah no that's fine I just um
um it just things are very difficult it
was a real challenge obviously getting
such a wide variety of people together
to try and coordinate something but um
yeah no I appreciate the answer thank
you I don't think being able to follow
her
that is we've been talking about this
policy uh this 2019
um reduced a little bit of protein
um just a few points as well but if
that's what we've obviously the main
theme to the council we know we're going
along about three or four years without
describing it and I really want to
promote you ask someone to write a steps
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
anyway
does that answer your question that
you've got
[Music]
um
yes
I appreciate if things have happened and
I appreciate obviously
it's in 2019 but not the house
we'll know that right uh thank you
question from Steve Banger uh you happy
with that answer that David was in back
then thank you David I mean
thank you and the the funding area of
the funding secondary reserves for
um
what we're going to talk the council in
December essentially we're probably just
use it from working capital essentially
in the first instance you know we saw
that about 20 million pounds it's better
deposites in a hard money with Goldman
Sachs
into this fund and going to return the
36 percent
so that's what we'd probably do in the
first instance
um
financial and also
um it still seems to be
done in the main
that's not the area that's causing us
the biggest issues on temporary
accommodation but the reason the half a
million funding that comes from day look
they sort of Sleepless so that's why
maybe don't scroll down the road provide
funding
the ideas into the houses properties to
house larger families but this is what
we've got at the moment see you right
now here we've got in the biggest
cause of the temperature accommodation
expenditure pressure we've got which is
poundless and balancing one
accommodation but every little helps
[Music]
another one from Shirley
[Music]
um
are you happy with that yeah I mean I
just like to say I really appreciate you
know the um
the length of Janice and the hair
elsewhere so um yeah but it's a very
good answer thank you
sorry I'm sorry it's good
okay
there's no question in Union almost
strategy what is the composition you got
an answer there in China all right
um
[Music]
you play strategy are you happy with the
answer
now I'm going to say when I I wrote my
question
um before Monday's meeting and so I've
already emailed Audrey and
um
but uh you know I wrote the question to
just keep that in automatically
um and uh I'm just really pleased the
decision that was made
um in my late meeting and that obviously
we are really concerned about Victoria
and
the thought was made that money should
go there and London's meeting to the
decision indeed
um
[Music]
[Music]
play areas
um
I know obviously we're on the huge
financial constraints here but do we
actually offer
um some Financial benefits and councils
taking on things
um taking out what we would have
allocated with the maintenance maybe or
um so it would be an increase burden on
the current
[Music]
have happened
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
next time
the possibility of taking over the past
I've got no idea
is very important
I have budgets that I had bought and
we're not going to be in a position to
do very much
I think he put his could inspire
um
[Music]
resulting strategy aliens gone through
and targeted specific parts
to approach those Parish Council and
Town Council to think it would be
possible for them
only the ones that we own
foreign
[Music]
we were asking the council why the bank
account et cetera et cetera if they
wanted to take it down but only if it
would join up on everything else but
part of that it's I I well the only
thing I know about it is if if they
don't want to take these things on we
will get rid of them because there's a
lot of money
foreign
[Music]
welcome back
but
um yeah
[Music]
yeah
yeah
um thank you very much so yeah we were
told that well there's another meeting
and at least yeah I think it says here
when we make the employee today
maybe in points of agency work to take a
bunch of Enforcement cases what we're
looking at is what one we have afternoon
doctor
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]